uh so uh i i think
uh omid would you would you help in the
videos um and yes
if the panelists are available and
they're ready they can share their
screens in the order that they're
presenting no no they're not going to be
uh they're not going to be sharing their
screens could you pin their videos
oh of course it's done last time yeah
okay
okay so um okay so let me let me
introduce the panelists while
while that's happening so the
panelists are garnet chan from from
caltech
he's garnet is
is is one of the one of the masters at
this
at this intersection of theoretical
chemistry uh condensed matter physics
and quantum information so it's
particularly appropriate for
for uh for this talk actually this you
know uh
uh mathias matthias's talk ranged over
quite a quite a number of subjects and
so this panel is
uh is really um you know very
appropriate for that um
um our next panelist is uh
matt hastings who
who is a condensed matter theorist uh
from
um uh also from microsoft
quantum and um he he has done
a number of things but from you know the
thing that's closest to my heart is that
he's uh
he's one of the one of the central
players in
in this in establishing and doing
uh work in this area of uh quantum
hamiltonian complexity
um our next panelist is
is misha luken uh from harvard he's
um i i believe he's uh uh
you know to me he's unique in the sense
that he's uh he's
he he's also both had a
great theorist as well as an
experimentalist and his uh
he's one of the his i think the
principal architect
of this spectacular work on on coal item
systems for doing
quantum simulations uh at harvard
um and finally our last panelist is
uh gregita whaley um who is my colleague
here at uh at berkeley
and um you know she did um
uh some of the earliest work on on the
coherence three subspaces
uh ford for doing uh quantum fault
tolerance
um uh she's she's also a quantum chemist
which is
extremely appropriate uh for what's
being done here and
um and you know we've both been
uh co-directors of the berkeley quantum
computing center
you know which started in 2001 it was
probably one of the first
quantum centers around so uh welcome
everybody to the panel
uh so the the the plan is
to to have each of the panelists talk
for
you know about two to three minutes to
get their perspectives on
on matthias's talk as well as their
their their general
uh opinions and then um and then we'll
go on to a panel discussion and
audience questions so uh well welcome
everybody and
uh to the panelists and and maybe we
could start with
uh uh alphabetically with garnet
hey hi so uh so thanks for inviting me
to be part of this
um i'm taking care of my baby right now
so
i may have to dash off depending on what
i hear but
he seems to be okay right now um
yeah so so i thought it was very it was
very thoughtful talk i
enjoyed it very much um i think you know
there are many topics that matters
matthias covered so if i limit myself to
quantum chemistry um i think the the big
question that needs to be addressed
if one's using phase estimation um is
the problem of state preparation
and as we all know that limits the power
phase estimation in a theoretical sense
so the real question is practically uh
you know is it a problem or or not
is it easy to obtain an initial state
with good overlap or not
and certainly i mean for some problems
it's not but problems where it's very
easy to
obtain such a state often other ones are
very easy to do classically
so in the catalytic cycle that matthias
showed for example those were systems
where there's very good overlap with a
mean field state
but one would argue that those problems
are not the most challenging ones
classically right so
so classically you can find many
problems where say the overlap with a
mean field state is maybe
very small even in a small system you
know maybe 10 to the minus three to the
minus four
something like that um so that adds a
significant
refactor to phase estimation um
and if one scales up then asymptotically
of course if we just take a box of water
if you're just not very exotic if you
just take 30 water molecules
you know the overlap drops below a
percent already so with a mean field six
so one you know these are things i think
one would have to grapple with
um in the evaluation of these costs
that's my that's
perhaps the main point that i would make
great thank thanks uh garnett uh
and matt do you have um
uh yeah it was um i
very much appreciated the perspective
that um chemistry
is one of the natural applications of
quantum computers rather than big data
so um just one third i mean this is
almost an obvious thing but
i think it's not said enough in the
field i
hear a lot of people saying things like
well we'll see what algorithms we get
once the computers are built
and certainly that's true but i think we
should always have in the back of our
mind
that um if you propose a quantum
algorithm you should have at least
some reason to think it will work and i
don't even mean a proof but some basic
reason
so chemistry is a natural application
because it's high-dimensional linear
algebra and quantum computers can do
that but
when we get into things like
optimization
let me draw an analogy like if we talk
about simulated annealing this is a
classical algorithm
used in practice with many developments
over the years
there's still a lot of work in proving
when or if it does or does not work but
there's like an intuitive reason it
works you know it's okay well we're just
constantly lowering energy and every now
and then we raise it up and come back
down
then you might ask about the adiabatic
algorithm where it's it's sort of a
quantum version of simulated annealing
where you start with a target
hamiltonian which is some objective and
you
have a driving term and you interplay
between them and you should say why
should we ever believe this works and i
think there's a higher bar for quantum
because when you talk about quantum
you have interference and interference
is very subtle you know if you
have some idealized situation
interference can look beautiful but if
you just imagine
you know you look at an interference
picture in something in optics where
there's noise it just looks like garbage
and junk and this is exactly what you
see with the adiabatic algorithm that if
you have
some toy examples that are perfectly
tuned you can see a speed up
if you have uh mesh and andres gillian
have worked on this recently some
constructed examples you can show a
speed up with an approvable speed up in
an oracle model
but there's now overwhelming evidence
that if you put in sort of a
generic target function chosen randomly
or from in
industry that actually the interference
hurts you
that it it gives leads to localization
and this is kind of a property so i
think there just needs to be
this memory that like if we want to
propose a quantum algorithm it should be
something
that uh we have a just at least some
heuristic reason to think we can make
the interference help us so i think
chemistry is really
one of the natural reasons because it's
exactly what a quantum computer can do
thanks thanks matt i'm so glad you said
that yeah yeah
so i like wise very much to enjoy the
talk
uh thank you matthias so i agree
completely that the first applications
of
these quantum machines will be
scientific
and it's absolutely clear also that
simulations will be the first
uh uh kind of examples and
um in particular simulating dynamics i
think that's really i would say
kind of the lowest hanging fruit it's
just simply because
already with systems which we have now
we can go to
corners of hilbert space where no one
has ever been
and you know this is basically the kind
of you know
work which is the kind of path which i
would say is kind of
totally right for discovery and i think
we are already kind of entering the
regime you know certainly in our
experiments and also in others
where we basically you know trying to do
kind of motivated a little bit like what
matt says we need to have some you know
no
you know you know some good ideas for
places to look and whenever we look we
almost always discover something new and
i would say
the areas like you know dynamics in
particular but also
for example you know you you know
developing methods to device entangled
quantum matter i think it's another
you know you know direction so i mean
maybe the main application
here will be you know to help us to
device
for example i have no topological
quantum computers
bigger quantum computers but i view that
that certainly as a kind of
low you know kind of
near-term uh um
uh you know direction you know you know
to explore and
maybe one comment that i that i have
about you know actually maybe i also was
a little bit confused about your example
um about you know involving izing models
so
i i i think you know i understand the
argument about
analog devices maybe not be as robust in
the long term but you know i would say
you know right now
you know we should just go with what
works and many of the
you know programmable devices they can
be operated either as gate devices or
analog devices and we can actually
creatively combine maybe sometimes we
should use
adiabatic state preparation and then
perform quantum phase estimation so
i think that's what kind of uh you know
the ideas that people
put forward for things like co-design i
think these are really now we are in a
position where we can really take
advantage of this
and just one last maybe small point you
know
you know i completely agree with matt
about
you know like you know if one starts
looking for
you know algorithms for optimization or
maybe sampling where i think sampling
perhaps quantum computers are a little
bit better
suited for i mean one should do it
wisely
but you know that said you know i think
also in this area
you know we are also at the point that
we
can have we create machines where we
cannot simulate aerodynamics we can
we can run things which would be
extremely hard to impossible to to
simulate and i think this kind of
dialogue where on one hand
you kind of have some intuition you know
for places to look for
i mean it's also good to have like
negative results for places where
not to look for but really for example
sorting classes of problems optimization
or sampling
where you know we could at least have
some quantum speed up i think
this you know i i feel that this is
you know really worthwhile and i would
say relatively near-term goal
great yeah that's talking
all right thank you matthias that was a
great talk i
really actually appreciated the the
beginning when you actually
really did a careful analysis of the
clock time the effect of the clock time
uh not only in computation but also in
reading and readout that was uh
something we don't often see a lot and
that's really important caveat
so i'd like to um say a little bit about
um
the quantum chemistry so you focused on
um phase estimation and or
even if one has related uh techniques
for
fully full tolerant quantum computation
that of course
does rely as garnet says on having a
good initial
or having some initial state that has
some overlap with the
the true state and some guarantee of
that so
and there's that means you have to have
a lot of good answers and that's
a lot of the focus of those of us that
are working with
are trying to implement um various parts
of quantum chemistry on these machines
are actually focused
on the same goal namely generating um
good answers and i'd be curious i mean
so the goal in the nisk machines
is to because of the constraints of low
depth quantum circuits
is to generate efficient representations
and so i'd be curious as to what you see
this seems to be a common goal whether
you're doing this
or whether you're doing tolerant quantum
computation
and specifically in terms of the
dynamical correlation problem which is
where you say
you sort of landed right now with the
catalysis problem
that's a place which is really right for
input
from classical computational quantum
chemistry where there are all these
tensor factorization
methods and new approaches coming out
you know basically
almost monthly um so i
i i would like to know you know what you
feel is the role that
quantum computing on a nisk device would
have to play in all of this because i
feel it's in fact
in a way synergistic with looking at the
long term
approach with um one phase estimation
and also what do you see that there are
things that
that the classical computational
chemistry can take back
from this all this very exciting work
being done on new anzac says and new
ways to understand the copper cluster
algorithm and so on
great thanks thanks uh so matthias do
you have a
something to respond to
about this yes
so let me respond
to negative
yes we need new types of answers is to
describe it
i think the big value in finding those
and on something like
niger
that that's answer this will be to find
good neutral states that we could then
use
the problems with the problem i see
what we see with nega variation
and methods is that they aren't exact
there's always an error
and phase estimation would give us
really hey here this is this is really
the the eigen state then
the value of nisk machine i want to come
back to
[Music]
to what what misha said that really we
can use those machines
in an analog way in a hybrid way
and that way it is much more powerful
than just using them
them in a gate model way with just the
gate model i'm skeptical because if you
want to achieve for
an interactive problem of 100 orbitals
let's say
if you want to do it chief
chemical accuracy in the energies on a
nisk machine
the error rates have to be extremely low
as you know
but maybe you don't have to achieve
chemical accuracy maybe if you're
developing an approach that would give
you say a set of energy levels and give
you the right ordering
of those energy levels for a
particularly for a complicated system
like your
catalytic systems maybe that would
already be very important
yeah and sufficient and also you don't
need to you don't need to restrict
yourself to a variational approach
either
okay so you can start from that yeah
yeah
and and then do something as late i
guess i agree with that
but then why do you but then i say
really use the power of the analog
machine
yeah so
i may ask a question um so so
can we um i'm slightly unclear here
you know i think nisha brought up the
issue of programmability which seems
quite important
so once you once you have a programmable
machine and it's not error corrected
it's essentially a programmable analog
machine so
uh so now could you you know
you're further dis distinguishing
between a programmable analog machine
which does a restricted gate set versus
versus something else and can you say
what the something else
is i would say just use all of the
native operations the machine has
and don't limit yourself to just the
standard gate set
i agree completely that's exactly i
think that's a recipe for
the progress in the near term right that
is what people call co-design right you
just really need to
try as much as possible kind of use your
negative interactions to encode the
problem in the most efficient way
and this might not be enough but then
what you need to do on the top
you know you don't need to start from
scratch so misha
i mean i definitely agree that this
would be better but i'm curious perhaps
you can tell me
if you're given some chemistry
hamiltonian that's phrased to some
fairly arbitrary looking four fermi
terms
without sort of programmability and
really implementing rotations in c not
gates and so on is there a good way to
implement that more natively
yeah it is you know this specific you
know
um this specific
example is definitely a challenge
uh you know you know but you know i
would say
you know there are ways to explore so
for example if you have
you know systems with long-range
interactions
right you can definitely start you know
kind of relaxing a lot of this
you know kind of you know assumptions i
mean for example
if you want also if you want to simulate
you know fermions
just just simulating fermions is
extremely costly
right with qubits you i mean that's
another that's another so i think these
are the directions which
i feel for chemistry specifically these
directions i would say i really
underexplored yeah
so i mean to to what extent this will
eventually
succeed you know okay it's an open you
know it's an open question but
we see many many examples you know and
you know
we see that the problem is many
algorithms are very easy to analyze once
you decompose things
into kind of gates and so on and you
know
it is also in terms of implementation
you know i think there are some theorems
you know showing that this kind of bang
bang you know short pulse controls you
know
they are sort of ideally would be the
best you know there were you know
mathematical theorems
which are proven but in practice it's
just not like this because
every time you hit your system you know
you might create some you know
some amount of kind of desired evolution
but then you also create some evolution
which is undesirable in principle you
can
always undo it you know in the next
steps but just in practice that's not
you know in particular if you're
if you're a highly entangled state if
the system is chaotic you know forget it
you know so these are the kinds of
things which i i think we are learning
it now
hard way and i think that's where
basically you know i i think that's an
area where algorithm design you know
you know hardware design and maybe
applications really need to
kind of converge you know i mean that's
at least one you know kind of direction
that i see
right um you know there there's uh
maybe maybe you can also open it up to
questions from the audience
i i see that marcus greiner has a
has a question marcus do you want to
um yes hello sorry i didn't realize that
we were still within the panel
but right i just wanted to follow up on
the idea of um
using fermions to natively implement
fermionic degrees of freedom
um um kind of like if i think about
optical lattice for example if you make
this more programmable right
um like a hybrid model it seems really
interesting and i think there's actually
not even much understanding right now
um other than that is potentially very
powerful but
uh much understanding how this exactly
maps of course you can always map it
uh to a qubit system but it has a lot of
overhead
in particular it seems to uh always turn
a local hamiltonian into a highly
non-local hamiltonian
and in this context uh um i wonder or
um i'm curious if there uh
our opinions on like how this um
how implementing uh uh freedom naturally
could also help in general
if you then for example realize it in a
local hamiltonian but this maps to a
non-local hamiltonian that
otherwise would be much harder to solve
so i would say once you have something
fault tolerant then then you go or
the then the negative the overhead
can be smaller constant only but in
the nisk area of something
analog that's really hard and so
for the nisk area i really like it's
the negative the
work that you do on using your pharmacy
atoms
to solve the fermionic model
that's the the much simpler
way of getting there actually one quick
question is it clear that once your
fault tolerant
that your quantum computer isn't
uh isn't better at implementing local
models it
it seems like it will still benefit from
some kind of locality and communicating
qubits far away
they'll always be harder in some way do
you think of this locality if you talk
about
uh quantum computing or not
so also
for non-local models the work with
[Music]
a constant
but you
can
in such a way that that it doesn't cost
you too much
so so can can you can some somebody say
uh what are the prospects of actually
implementing a fermionic quantum
computer
before before just one quick comment on
local local can
even if your computer is completely
non-local there can be some advantage
for simulating
if the hamiltonian you try to simulate
this local because there's some lee
robinson based methods that can
get you close to the theoretical optimum
uh for simulation because you can
perform simulation in local blocks and
stitch it together so there's some
advantage for locality
but maybe not maybe not so important
just worth mentioning
simulators
the audience there's this
markers and tillman and others
who've done it here for many years
already
misha what's the
or something like that so yeah so
reedberg atoms they kind of very
naturally
implement long-range interactions in a
kind of highly programmable way
so uh the reedberg atoms are kind of
more naturally suited for realization of
qubits
or you know like the the systems which
don't have it or
it then basically kind of tunneling
you know so sorry but um
so and you know in a way kind of maybe
that's one limitation of current hubbard
simulators that they always you know in
all of them the interactions are local
so
um i think for this kind of for the spin
qubit models we're already kind of
enjoying this
you know we're starting to explore this
kind of long-range interaction as a
as a controlled knob from for
programmability
so i mean it might be interesting to ask
you know questions if there are
you know chemic chemistry models where
you don't need to simulate
you know fermionic degrees of freedom
where
you know it's just to have basically
effective spin model
which potentially have long range
interactions could could be
already you know sufficient but on the
other hand i think
certainly you know people like marcus
and tillman they're also thinking how to
sort of
bring this you know this thing the best
of both worlds together how to
have both fermionic systems and
long-range interactions which i think
would go a long way towards
you know the kinds of things we are
discussing
i think uh eddie fary has a question
yes can you hear me okay hi everyone
well
i you know matt said something that
stimulated me
you know matt said that we should only
look for algorithms when we have good
reasons and understanding
and you know i think understanding is
very overrated
and i think that what i really do and
i think that we should look for things
where we have mathematical techniques
that allow us to proceed and i'll give
you an example the qaoa
i mean at the qaoa we were able to get
worst-case performance guarantees at the
shallowest depth we're able to
show in the last few years that by
averaging over
instances we could get new results we on
the sk
model we were able to average over
instances
take the n goes to infinity limit and
analyze the
algorithm at arbitrary depth we also
were able to show limitations of the
algorithm on random instances
of maximum independence set we were also
able to show that the algorithm
has quantum supremacy at the shallowest
depth
so it seems to me that you know instead
of
asking for insight we should go to a
place where we have
specific techniques and work on it
and yet the community seems
disinterested in that question
and i'm just pointing that out and i
don't think it's helpful
to say you need insight before you do it
that's just my opinion
um oh yeah it was eddie i mean there's
certainly a lot of
mathematical techniques of course that
is that that is valid too and i think
the stuff you're talking about is all
great work in terms of um
mathematical physics better
understanding of specific random models
um but if we want to ask
will qaoa for example in in the simplest
form of you know the simplest form i
know there's a lot of cases where you
might structure it or so on but
the thing we say we're gonna just take x
and some arbitrarily chosen objective
and optimize angles and do some fixed
number of rounds
you know whether this should work
i mean i think we should i don't know if
your belief is that it should work my
belief is that there's there's no
reason to think it would work and sort
of my belief gets down to this
understanding which is you know you had
this
really nice result showing that the max
three line two this was the first you
know i think this really created the
interest in that algorithm
um better performance than known for
classical items but very quickly was
followed up with
classical improvement and then um
there's a very simple classical album
that just matches the performance of
qaoa which is just initialized spins in
a random classical configuration and
everybody moves a little bit towards
their neighbor
yeah matches well that was the case
where you know qaoi got the excitement
was put equals one and then
continued work you know i did work on
other models of p equals one and then
there was followed by someone else at p
equals two it's just seeming like
these simple classical algorithms are
outperforming qaoa as far as i can tell
at every fixed depth
but regardless of whether or not they're
outperforming it you know in the details
i think if you get down to like why was
kyo working was because it was mimicking
that
move a little bit towards where you're
trying to go you know you're trying to
get towards where your neighbors pushed
you so just move a little bit towards it
and this is this is sort of evidence
that that's why it was working because
these classical algorithms are matching
its performance these ones which just do
that incredibly simple like
do a little local update at some fixed
depth and do it for some number of
rounds
um those match the qaoa and uh
um so if we want to think the qa i mean
disregarding all the beautiful
mathematical work on if we want to think
that it's going to be a practical
algorithm
there should be some argument like why
doing this local update quantumly might
be better and i don't
i don't see that um yeah well i don't i
don't know i mean maybe
i don't talk about it but for example we
were able to show that you know
on random instances of maximum
independent set
that um the qaoa would not could
there were barriers to it unless the
depth grew logarithmically with the
problem
size so i certainly believe that if you
take
fixed depth qaoa in the limit as the
problem size gets infinite
except for the sk model for because that
model you see the problem well maybe we
shouldn't get too much into
it we don't want to get started but i
don't want to overdo it
in terms of this specific thing but um
i don't have a good reason to think it
should work but i also don't have a good
reason to think it shouldn't work
i mean who knows maybe the qaoa when you
um you know take it to depth lock with
mcnane
will beat gomez williamson i don't know
i honestly don't know yeah i mean i
don't think there's any evidence it
won't
it may but but let me so let me just
yeah i'll stop talking i don't want to
get to but you know if we think it does
and i think it's very interesting to ask
what it may do and to ask what
completely local classical algorithms
may do these kind of local classical
items we do at that depth
but i think if you were to succeed or
someone were to succeed in getting like
a really
you know whatever and there's all kinds
of interesting things you can do and
it's great because it's a framework for
addressing these it's i think the good
thing is this is a
framework for addressing them but there
should be some sense of
um how we should pick these uh these
angles that might lead to appropriate
constructive interference because as
soon as you get beyond the
high girth graph you start having
different local structure you'll see not
just the tree and then
you have to make the interference work
out right for all these configurations
just my feeling and of course everyone
may
be led in their own way but my thing is
like you should have some motivation for
picking the picking up to make the
interference work right so maybe
well let's i'll stop there so can i
yeah that's fine everybody work you know
motivates themselves in their own way
and you know that's fine yeah
i don't need to have a preconceived
notion or i don't
have to understand like for example the
um
the the nam tree where we showed that
you know the quad by quantum walk you
could be
the best classical algorithm for
evaluating an entry i have no insight in
that
i don't know why that works none
and you had to beat the best classical
algorithm
did you start with some really serious
intuition when you
absolutely not absolutely not let me
absolutely not
we were working on a different problem
you know in retrospect
is perfect because it's it's a case
where
you can see what the interference does
maybe only after you've got it you can
see what the interface is i can't
anyway but but no but let me just answer
umash's question umesh said
you know no we did not what happened was
we were looking at a different
problem and we for with quantum walks
and we saw that there was a recursion
involved in that problem and then we saw
that that recursion was the net
so then we solved the nand tree problem
we didn't set out to solve
that problem we discovered the recursion
which was the solution to the mandatory
problem
by looking at a different problem
you know so i think that's much more
typical of how you make progress
is you try things and then you solve
other problems
and that's why i'm not warm to this
position of you know
knowing what you're doing in advance i
think it's better to just try
anyway i'm going to stop i
if i can add something there i mean i
think it takes both
i mean there's many different kinds of
approaches and
all approaches should be the community
as a whole should try all those
approaches
absolutely community should try it maybe
yeah all right so i just wanted to come
back to the suggestion about
um maybe simulating uh quantum chemistry
with
long-range spin models so garnets back
here i mean there is
activity in the classical chemistry
community
classical classical quantum chemistry
community to make spin models for
for some types of quantum chemistry
systems anything especially for excited
states and maybe ghana say something
more about that i don't know how
long-range they are
but that's certainly something that
might in this context of these catalytic
systems be useful
to just sort of explore the uh
in mathias in your in your sense of
exploring the entire landscape of this
uh excited reactive system
it might be useful to to map out that
landscape with an effective spin model
first
yeah i think there are i mean you know
spin models emerge from
chemistry right so there are like
the same condensed math systems
where the low energy physics is
described by spin models and then take a
finite chunk of that that you might see
in a molecule then
the low energy physics is to some
approximation described by spin models
and that they are of course good good
choices for
like more simplistic quantum simulations
although
at the level of um you know once
targeting high accuracy the
approximation that you're
making by reducing the spin model you
know removes the you know the claim that
one is
obtaining but but maybe one direction
that one could pursue is to try to
basically benchmark
the this you know the chemistry kind of
codes against you know accurate solution
of this you know kind of highly
entangled you know
highly correlated long-range models so i
think this okay
i think this is a kind of you know
the convergence of different directions
which i think you know our community
would really benefit from i think you
know that would be
in my view that would be you know
very good you know yeah i mean i think
that you know these
um these faithful comparisons of
classical cost versus
you know careful estimation of quantum
costs are certainly
important right that's it and um um
and you know i'll come back to my
original point where i i think that
the biggest uncertainty in that coastal
perhaps the biggest
factor that when we need to grapple with
is the state preparation cost in
the quantum algorithm so i think we do
not have enough information there
but um yeah i agree it's good
we're good to have validated systems
where we do this type of comparison
i have another question to mathias do
you really or does microsoft really need
what did you say eight or nine digits of
back precision
in both energies
i want to measure things to merely heart
treat their needs
okay in
the total energies of course we are only
interested in the relative energies
[Music]
can make it easier but if we want to go
to millihard is then we have
to propagate for a time that is the
inverse familiarity
so the the time and need for
the propagation really depends on
the energy accuracy that they need
that's if you take the entire molecule
though then right
you want all the electrons because if
you're only considering
i okay so let's say when i look at
a smaller active space i still need to
get to the same position
yeah yeah really hard and so the time i
need to propagate is still the same
advantage if i throw out the big term
the advantage is they can maybe do
bigger time steps
so the complexity can go down so when i
remove all of the
big terms in the model and focus on the
smaller ones
only for an active space then i may be
able to do
bigger time steps but still have to go
to the same time
so yes there is an advantage restricting
the model
yeah but it's indirect through the
through the time steps
yeah yeah misha i just want to make one
point to cut you know
actually about the discussion between
matt and eddie so
i personally think we need actually
kind of many more examples you know like
qa
you know because and you know i
completely i
you know it you know it's completely
clear that is not cannot be you know
one cure for all and i mean you're a
completely right matter developing this
intuition
when these coherences would you know
when these things would interfere in the
right way maybe that will be a solution
maybe this is where
you know examples where algorithm you
know certain algorithms like qa you know
certain graphs
that they will perform very well you
know and having this kind but you know
this kind of you know examples and
intuitions and
remember now we are in this you know era
of quantum discovery where we have
actually machines with you know over you
know
200 qubits which can actually you know
kind of test these things beyond this
short shallow depths you know where you
know maybe we could you know outperform
you know eddie's you know insightful you
know proofs and you know
and both kind of test things beyond
these shallow depths i think that's
this is a very very special time in that
sense and you know i think
we just need more examples of this of of
these times things we could try but
again you know kind of
with direction where to look you know so
let me let me agree with you and let me
also say that
you know um draw a distinction between
how we look when we do research and how
we talk when we talk about
our outlook for what may happen i mean
we may try all these things but
if we want to say that we think not just
that it may work but if like we want to
be honest and say like
we think this will work not that it may
work but that we think there is a good
chance that this will work
then we can do it as you say using some
simulators or we can do it using
really high performance numerical
simulation using
and attention to scaling methods maybe
we're limited up to perhaps around 40
qubits depending upon what machine we
use what kind of
accuracy we need properties of the
circuits but then
not just you know i
i see too many papers on the archive
where they're like oh we did this
circuit at 20 qubits
with all these optimizations and it
beats some classical algorithm which
scales to you know
whatever it needs to be really a careful
scaling work and this is the kind of
thing matthias and i did
with dave wecker and others um some of
the stuff he talked about
you know really looking classically the
sizes you can get increasing the size
and paying careful attention to scaling
if there is to be a claim that
that something will work so we must try
all these things but
absolutely i think that kind of that's
you know i mean the careful benchmarking
and understanding
you know i would say at this point is
just really understanding scaling would
be really
kind of i mean it would point to us i
mean like
we are you know we are kind of looking
and just you know in a wide open space
you know
and basically at this point everything
you know right you know any direction we
could you know
you know provide basically and i'm
talking about us as a community i think
would be super helpful you know and i
think you know if you have you know
one example with one qubit system this
would inform
greatly what you should be doing with
other qubit systems or
also in terms of algorithms i absolutely
agree that you cannot just
you know do basically simulation or non
small you know system and just
make grand conclusion you know from that
but i think we're in a position when we
can start
at least looking over like a decade in
terms of number of qubits i think that's
what is very very special you know
so so yeah just so it sounds like the
conclusion is we should we should be
we should feel free to think about
anything explore anything
but maybe we should we should think
twice before publishing these things
no i'd say one should have a reason for
pursuing something
motivation yeah so you know we are um
uh this this was a fantastic uh talk in
the panel uh
we can continue the discussion in gather
town so i posted the link on chat
uh so for for everybody you know
panelists uh
uh attendees anybody who would like to
like to join and continue the discussion
so um again you know i'd like to really
thank uh
matthias troyer for for a very
thought-provoking uh
colloquium and and to the panelists for
uh
for for this you know fantastic
discussion
and actually also also to the audience
because um
it was a you know there were it was
really a vigorous discussion
uh um so um
we'll be taking a break from the
colloquium next week it's spring break
here officially in berkeley
i don't know what that means this year
but uh but for what it's worth and then
we'll continue
the week after on the 30th with uh yuan
tang
uh speaking about uh quantum machine
learning
so uh so again thank you all and see you
at gather town
thank you thank you bye